for our main story tonight
i'd actually like to talk about how the
president spent the first half of his
week because for some reason
in the midst of 40 million americans
unemployed 100
000 americans dead and racial tensions
boiling over
he chose to spend his days focusing on
this president trump overnight taking to
twitter to take
on twitter along with other social media
giants for what he calls political bias
it comes after twitter for the first
time added a fact check footnote on two
of his tweets that called mail-in
ballots
substantially fraudulent yeah twitter
fact-checked the president's tweets
they're also apparently fact-checking
other tweets as well but clearly not all
of them because we just tweeted
luke is the best hemsworth and so far
that has not been flagged as a damaging
lie
and come on twitter either your system
works or it doesn't it is a known fact
that the order goes chris hemsworth liam
hemsworth
no hemsworths then luke
but it is worth taking a look at the
underlying statement that caused twitter
to act
trump's claim that voting by mail in
this year's elections will be
substantially fraudulent because that is
a favorite subject of his
he's tweeted about it a ridiculous
number of times in the last two months
and he brings it up
constantly mail ballots a very dangerous
thing for this country because they're
cheaters
they go and collect them they're
fraudulent in many cases the mail
ballots
are corrupt in my opinion and they
collect them and they get people to go
in and sign them and then they
they're forgeries in many cases it's a
horrible thing
now what he just said there was complete
and actively harmful to the
democratic process but in a weird way
it's almost comforting to hear him
busting out his classic 2016 hits about
voter fraud and rigged elections
it brings you back to a simpler time
doesn't it when we could go to
restaurants freely
we had no idea what zoom was and we were
sure that an obviously unqualified
presidential candidate was going to lose
in the historic landslide
oh 2016 you truly were the good old
only less horrifying in context days and
the thing is
voting by mail is a popular idea 70
of us are in favor of allowing any voter
to vote by mail if they want to
and if this pandemic continues into the
fall as it almost certainly will
many voters will want to do exactly that
because think about it
holding an in-person election during a
pandemic is an
absolute nightmare elections usually
involve hundreds of people
cycling in and out of a single enclosed
location plus
polling places are often located in
communal buildings like schools and
nursing homes and many of those are out
of the question right now
even keeping poll workers safe can be
difficult because according to one
estimate
while the typical voter may encounter
only about 20
other people when they go to the polls
the typical poll worker will encounter
about
700 and many are understandably
concerned about that
i never thought i'd say this in my time
but this really scares me this kind of
thing i never thought i'd see it
for mcgee and a majority of poll workers
they're retired
in their 60s or 70s and health experts
say this age group is among some of the
most vulnerable to the virus
even if we have a line of 10 people how
are we going to keep everybody
you know safe from the germs we have a
touch screen
we'll have to wipe that down every time
are we supposed to have people
bring their own pencil no of course not
and not just because they shouldn't have
to but also who the hell owns a fully
functioning pencil i mean sure
you might have one with a usable eraser
but an unusable tip
or maybe you have one with a sharpened
tip but the eraser's gone or maybe
you've got one with a functioning tip
but the race is all hard and leaves like
a brown streak on the paper and yeah
you could sharpen any of these pencils
but with what
a pencil sharpener you don't own one of
those or unless you do in which case
just ask me this
where is it exactly if you think you're
in any way prepared to bring a working
pencil to a polling station and you my
friend are living in a
fantasy world now that woman
actually decided not to work her state's
primary out of fear for her safety and
many voters share her concerns but
not all state officials are addressing
those concerns especially well just
listen to missouri's governor mike
parson
offer advice ahead of next week's local
elections there you know i hope people
feel safe but
to go out and vote but if they don't you
know the number one thing is their
safety should be number one
so if they don't um then then
don't go out and vote you know you know
i don't know like i've ever heard myself
say that but but you know if you didn't
feel safe then i wouldn't do that
well hold on there voting is a right
it has to be easy to understand and
accessible to everyone
unlike say hbo max what the
is that by the way does anyone actually
know how do i get it
i'm on it and i don't know and why is it
so purple
it's like i'm watching television from
inside grimace's
and not in a good way now there are a
lot of ways to mitigate the dangers here
but perhaps the biggest
is expanding the option to vote by mail
you know the thing that trump lies about
so often
twitter finally decided to step in so
tonight let's take a look at why the
option of voting by mail
is so necessary why concerns about it
are often overblown and why talking
about it right now is actually really
important and let's start with the fact
that we actually have a pretty good
lesson for just how badly an election
during a pandemic can be bungled thanks
to
wisconsin they held their primary just
last month and it was
absolute chaos partly because their
democratic governor had tried to delay
it
only to be thwarted by the
republican-controlled state legislature
and supreme court
and the republican assembly speaker
robin vos tried to reassure people that
everything was safe while volunteering
as a polling place but something about
how he delivered that message
was a little unconvincing you think
voting in person is putting people at
risk today
i don't i mean i look at this and say to
myself that we have every single
opportunity to be safe
do you robin do you because you're
sending two
very different messages there your mouth
is saying don't worry
everything's safe and cool but it's
being slightly undercut by the fact your
dress code
is chernobyl casual and unsurprisingly
many didn't buy his assurances due to
safety concerns there was a
massive reduction of polling sites in
some big cities with
milwaukee's 180 polling sites being
reduced down to just
five resulting in massive lines and
adding to the chaos was the fact a
record number of male ballots were
requested
hundreds of which never arrived or
arrived late all of which
resulted in sites like this
immuno-compromised woman casting her
ballot
while wearing a garbage bag and no one
should have to wear a garbage bag
because they're trying to vote you
should only have to wear one because
you're trying to shed excess water
weight
so you look extra jacked oh yeah i
haven't stopped my pump routine
just because of the lockdown i still
catch the diesel express every day
the sun don't shine before this swollen
eclipse runs its course
you might as well put me in a tortilla
with some salsa and lime because my beef
is shredded and look having been put
into this position
you can kind of understand why the
voters in wisconsin were so
pissed this is so wrong this is just so
wrong this this election should have
been called off
you know they're telling us to stay in
the house and you know stand
six feet from each other but then one of
the most important
times they're forcing us to come out
here
stop playing politics with our lives
yeah
that must have been frustrating because
you can't pretend coronavirus has
stopped for a day
in order to hold an election it doesn't
give a
about democracy it's just one of the
many ways that covid19 is the donald
trump of infectious diseases it's also
of course
weirdly shaped and disproportionately
harmful to minorities
and remember that was just a primary
november's general election will have a
much higher turnout so
how do we prevent what happened in
wisconsin from happening 50 times over
well one obvious answer
is to make it easier to vote by mail but
some argue
that that's a dangerously radical
proposition everyone's afraid everyone's
rethinking
how we do things should we do it a new
way and that's okay we should be
open-minded
why haven't we had mail-in ballots for
the last 230 years
maybe the reason is mail-in ballots are
an invitation to
widespread fraud and manipulation and if
you want to rattle people's faith in the
system that we've had for centuries
maybe you would do that i don't know oh
i'm sorry
you don't know oh well first off tucker
thanks so much for admitting that
one of the biggest problems with modern
discourse is that people think admitting
a lack of knowledge is a sign of
weakness when it's not is it
it's how we learn and grow as
individuals so it's really heartening to
see someone in your position
admit that they don't have all the facts
facts like for instance
that we've had voting by mail since the
civil war and that one in four americans
actually cast a mail ballot in the last
two federal elections so
your premise that voting by mail is a
new idea that would shatter democracy
it's in fact completely wrong
and deeply stupid that's not a
reflection on you though is that you
just engaged in a dialogue
in good faith so thank you unless you
weren't doing that
in which case go yourself you human
boat shoe
so clearly the question isn't should we
have voting by mail at
all because we already do it's how hard
should we make it
and depending on where you live the
answer to that question can vary
widely for instance if you live in these
five states
congratulations you already have
universal all-male voting where a
ballast is automatically sent
to every eligible voter now if you live
in these 29 states
you can request an absentee ballot for
any reason
if you live in these 16 states you do
have to provide a reason to vote
absentee and while
these 11 have at least in some cases
allowed the fear of coronavirus to be a
valid one
these five states have not also
almost no states have decided whether or
not it'll be a valid excuse for the
general election this november and
that's not even getting into
some of the other restrictions that
states have put in place the most
ridiculous of which is alabama
where to vote absentee you have to
submit a photocopy of your photo id
in addition to signing it before a
notary or two witnesses
and the argument for putting limit on
voting by mail is that if you don't do
that
people will just cheat think about the
voter registration records in states
that have not been purged
by that i mean dead people have not been
removed
you can request an absentee ballot in
that name
have it mailed to a different address
saying you moved
but you know the person's dead and then
say you're back at the old address and
go and vote
okay now while that might sound
plausible to you at first
just think how many steps you'd have to
take to successfully make that happen
first you have to know a dead person
that's hard to do they're anti-social
then you have to know that they were
registered to vote when they were alive
then
you have to fill out a form to request
an absentee ballot email to your address
instead of theirs now to do that you'd
likely have to redo their entire voter
registration which will require you to
know personal information like
their address date of birth the last
four digits of their social security and
possibly their driver's license number
and date when it was issued but okay
let's say that you do all of this and
you get their ballot in the mail
you might also have to know what the
dead person's signature looks like to
convincingly forge it because it could
be compared
to their signature already on file and
you would better hope that that
notification of their death
never reaches the elections office
through any of the routes that it could
as
despite what just janine would have you
believe voter roles go through periodic
list maintenance including
cross-checking social security death
records and having done all of this
and remember told authorities where you
live if you're caught
you're risking several felonies which in
many states involve prison time
or to gain the grand total of one vote
it is a crime that's difficult high risk
and low reward it's as if
at the end of oceans eight we learned
that sandra bullock had gone to all the
trouble of breaking into the met gala
to steal a map of state quarters sandra
why that's twelve dollars and fifty
cents worth of quarters that's a
complete waste of your time
kate blanchett's time and most
importantly rihanna's time
and look fraud can happen in mail in
voting
opponents love to cite a 2005 bipartisan
report that said
absentee ballots remain the largest
source of potential voter fraud but what
they don't mention is
that in practice it's still incredibly
rare
in oregon in 2016 out of the more than
two million votes cast by mail
there were just 54 cases of suspected
voter fraud
that is 0.002 percent
and to hear oregon's former secretary of
state tell it there's a pretty good
explanation for that
vast majority of oregonians are
don't care about politics to the level
that they're willing to risk prison time
for it yeah of course they don't the
only vote oregonians would risk prison
over would be a vote to get portland
trailblazer damian lillard into the mvp
conversation you know what they'd be
right to do that
dame dollar for life and look i am not
saying that voting by mail is perfect
mailed ballots are rejected at a higher
rate than those cast in person and it
doesn't work for all communities
some people with disabilities need to go
to an in-person voting place for help
casting a ballot
and places like native american
reservations and remote alaskan villages
may have unreliable postal service plus
if you vote by mail
you probably don't get one of those i
voted stickers which if you live in
louisiana
means you might not have got this actual
sticker featuring a truly
excellent pelican look at this absolute
king it's hard to pick my favorite part
of this his steely blue gaze
his crown that says the state of
louisiana has a monarch
and i am it or his prominently displayed
earring despite
not having any ears to speak of no
question here
that large water bird what an
incredible motivator to get out and vote
in louisiana that will obviously
backfire when everyone
right in that pelican as their choice
for governor but
advocates argue that vote by mail is
still
a good idea that would reduce obstacles
to civic participation but that
in and of itself may be why it's become
so controversial
conservative opponents often speculate
that any increased participation
would benefit democrats despite the fact
researchers have consistently found
that it hasn't obviously helped one
party or the other and yet
some are willing to go to extremes to
fight this texas
a g threatened to prosecute anyone who
encouraged people to get an absentee
ballot
because they were afraid of the
coronavirus and the lieutenant governor
there
has been doing some truly trump caliber
level fear-mongering
when you have an opportunity to steal a
vote the democrats will take advantage
of it and this is what it's all about
there is no reason capital and capital
oh no reason that anyone under 65
should be able to say i'm afraid to go
vote have they been to a grocery store
they've been to walmart or they've been
to lowe's they've been home depot
have they been anywhere have they been
afraid to go out of their house no this
is a scam by the democrats to steal the
election
look far be it from me to challenge the
wisdom of a well-read guy whose
bookshelf is only half occupied by
footballs
but going to the grocery store doesn't
mean people aren't afraid it means they
need to eat
at a certain point hunger outweighs fear
which is also incidentally the official
slogan of taco bell
but even in states that try to fight it
the odds are that there will be a lot
more people voting by mail come this
fall
which brings us to our final point how
will states handle that well
first they need money fast some estimate
the costs of properly running the 2020
elections during the pandemic
could reach 4 billion and unfortunately
the cares act
directed just 400 million to states
which is just
nowhere near enough and this funding
needs to come quickly
some jurisdictions are going to struggle
to handle a high volume
of male ballots in fact take the swing
state of pennsylvania which only had 107
000 absentee ballots in their 2016
primary but
received applications for over 1.8
million
this year and coping with surges like
that
won't be easy it could require hiring
and training dozens of additional
workers to process ballots or
purchasing machinery costing up to a
million dollars per unit
and if you are going to do that you need
to decide
right now because machines like
high-speed scanners and sorters
can take several months to order and
safely install
all of which makes it more than a little
concerning that some
like missouri governor mike parson the
man you saw earlier telling voters to
stay at home
if they didn't feel safe some of them
have argued that everyone should relax
because there's just no rush to deal
with this right
now it's about repairing or being
prepared for clover 19 doing what we can
for that it's about getting the economy
started back up it's about people moving
back to work
there'll be time to talk about the
elections in november in august but
now's not the time for that there'll be
time for that but now is absolutely the
time to talk about this
you cannot prepare for an election the
same way you update your computer's
software by just
putting it off a month on end and
secretly hoping that maybe you'll be
dead before
you actually have to deal with it we
need to get this right
now and it doesn't stop there officials
should also be
communicating to voters exactly how to
get a mail-in ballot
when they need to do it by and how to
properly fill it out and there's
there's actually one last thing that we
may need to personally prepare ourselves
for and that is that
in november if there is as seems likely
a surge in mail in voting
it may take much much longer for all the
ballots to be counted in fact
we may not know who's won until a few
days after election day
and if it doesn't look good for donald
trump look for him to use that to show
discord
among his supporters i'm just kidding of
course he'll win in a landslide and his
victory speech will be taking a on
the stage to thunderous applause
that's really in keeping with the vibe
2020 has set so far
but regardless there are a few things
that you can do here
if your state does allow voting by mail
you can request
and return your absentee ballot early
this will help flatten the curve
of vote tabulating on election day and
as a reminder if you need a stamp
these little beauties are available for
two more weeks and there's there's
actually one last problem
that we may be able to help you with
here because if the thing that's
stopping you from voting
by mail is not being able to get a fun
free sticker
we have you covered there we've designed
four of them that you can print out at
home
including one that says i wanted people
to know i voted by mail so i printed out
this sticker
one that says i voted by mail with an
image of this hamster and a speedo
one featuring a ghost with an x through
it and the caption i'm not dead and i
voted by mail and finally
in the spirit of louisiana one featuring
this emu wearing a top hat with a nose
ring for no reason whatsoever
all of these are available for you at i
voted by mail.com and i would seriously
consider doing it
because if you vote by mail not only
will you be exercising your civic duty
you'll also be making tucker carlson
really mad
and what better incentive is there to do
absolutely
anything than that
you